per quanto mi riguarda ho sempre amato
questi luoghi
mi hanno sempre dato un senso di pace
per molti la morte significa fine viene
considerato un argomento da evitare
quotidianamente fingiamo che non
esistano
eppure di un luogo dall altro capo del
mondo in cui la morte in stretta
sintonia con la vita non parliamo di
tradizioni macabre manifesta a letto
parlando del dia de los muertos la mia
festa preferita ma per parlarvene al
meglio avrò bisogno di un messicano
eloquenti
no dai non dire così sei tu la persona
no tu sei e l'ho personalmente per le
valli esso un cappello di a dallo smer
tous perché appello delle marche il via
dallo smart o se la mia festa preferita
e non festeggio dura quasi una settimana
e ogni giorno vengono imbanditi
banchetti sulle tombe dei propri cari
i bambini giocano a pallone nei cimiteri
vi rendete conto che cosa dico i bambini
di santa fe e giocano con i nonni a lei
e per quanto assurdo possa sembrare
tutto ciò li aiuta a ricordare quando ci
portava decidere la nonna conosciuto
soltanto
racconti poi quando tornavo dal cimitero
con i regali era molto sentita dal sud
questa tradizione il 2 novembre arrivano
i cari defunti che portavano ideali ai
bambini della famiglia io in cornino
trovato quella cosa molto mark andrà
però stare zitta perché mai la nave
felici non arrivava come diciamo quando
sono arrivato ma 19 portare i doni
jaguar ricordate le ossa di morto erano
dei biscotti
questa mi sfugge devo dire per i 3
novembre era una bella tradizione ho
deciso che organizzare il mio funerale
ma tu style impazza fra una cosa di un
cattivo gusto ma spiace se non sei un
ipocrita pure quando non hai aiutata la
pensione di invalidità tu la chiamata
palma ottime notizie 6 invalida al cento
per cento
te lo ricordi allora la mamma ottime
notizie 6 invalida al cento per cento
però non diciamo mani sulla mia eredità
come dei giaguari sull'eredità che se
mio figlio 4 ma uno sciamano
sull'eredità un ragazzo di 30 anni mensa
69 quasi 32 33 qualcuno ci vuole non
facile del mio funerale ma adesso non lo
è più
la maggiore oggi vorrei organizzando per
anni fa bene di consumo
forse se sia formalizzato scusi è mio
suo non hanno trovato perché vorresti
classe quante ne va un po più fianco ma
senza tuttavia non è una scelta che
faccio questi due magnifiche montagne
sul catalogo per fargli che vi lasciamo
tutto fretta io no flaring maccanti mi
sembra motivo che se si stava bene
classe sarà kg dopo anche io so se fa
per lei perchè no forse proprio non ci
va bene mette male per carità alla piano
piano cioè se potevo che riprenda
volontario di massa postali dopo che
sapeva che ha poi dopo una modalità a
cercare qualcosa la cremazione è
qualcosina risparmia sicuramente ma lui
non la si può mettere dentro la casa
la matrioska diciamo che la cassava
bruciata insieme a morto quindi mesta
creva perché lei non metà sono tante le
che rimedia che le mie quelle da casa se
un bambino momento la legge dice che si
negava sovente tuta intera
se lega che guardi se non quella massima
onestà
qui siamo tutti uniti che dovrebbe dire
no cerchiamo di trovare la doppia
amichevole ma perché io stato bagnato 27
ma questi indica ma sei sicuro scusa ma
questi sono pieni di questi è stato si
dividono li sceglie quindi adesso c'è
nessuno adesso non c'è nessun problema
un caffè già preso grazie ad una
sigaretta sono riforme l'impressione che
insomma qui e poi santoro va comunque
non è matematica e pacchetto meno di
swiss cascaro fiori scrivo nostro
spallatori portato come gli spalatori
sembra che la casa di amor taciuto il
portiere questo con la cravatta celeste
paura pure gharian insetti bella
manifestazione la mal comune era un
affare destra positivo stato sentito
sempre chiesto tra maschi hanno nuovi
vuoi ma guardate risente di gioco nella
priorità ci sarà magari a vestina vela
prestito era conio anche perché magari
da morto annuncia non so agenti non
richiede una sistemata prima ha capito
io mettevo le sole mare per moderare
l'incontro il pagamento al finanziamento
piena era detto attestamento ci vai di
parenti e quindi gli accollo pure stare
anche in aree in faccia nessuno alza
come te ricky moneta che divise la
pagina ma che è
siediti lo sanno tutti esposito viene
tanto più funerali in anticipo ma da
qualche giorno e perchè beh lasciamo
stare che poi vuoi lasciare il braccio
di carson all'enfasi lavata importante
il fermo questo scrive il discorso
finale sono iniziando imbecille
paventato la carta e penna e scrive per
favore tu lo devi solo esporre però è la
fortuna di dire il discorso come fosse
due scomparti così agile e leggero ne
sai magari crimi ha 80 anni con
trasportino con occhi da cerbiatto punti
di fantini puntini bambi quindi termini
un attimo ma perché devo dire bambi
bambi camerano sospiro sull'amore bande
io staccata non tradirò mai però angeles
leggero con occhi da cerbiatto bambi
bandi bambi ok bambi bambino bambi bambi
senso che l'interpretazione sia ma non
la via maestra m gabriele non è mai
caduto a bisogna ripetere
il nome intanto vuole mettere bambi ma
gabriele bambi non è mai caduto con un
addome di fondamenta prendiamo una
licenza poetica utile di fondo di
fondamenta ai grattacieli ai grattacieli
pietoso lo farò mai una volta che lo
firmi questo diventa mai non averlo non
voglio malumori o brutti musica il
brutto music quando sei in vita quando
non scrivere più aggraziato comune di
tacchio potresti anche far mi fa il
funerale in notturna posso riciclare
questo discorso nel caso tu muoia prima
di me no no no io ho piace trovava in
carcere ci ha segnalato bambini m come
wi fi nelle fotografie sono venuto in
realtà per quello che il discorso della
già scritto questo benito ha scosso per
quanto se c'erano tipico giorni di
persone darvi tutti magari kg continua
quindi invece le spese illuso ordini
questa macchina mi sa ke siete che
sembra un apostata ora facciamo una
forma del funerale del ci credo ma
davanti alla porta gabriele terribili di
sentire i muri quello di fotografia e io
che cambiano non lo so
madonna guarda che oggi sembra quel
cazzo di bambi con quella cazzo di
farfalla quando gioca con la cazzo di
farfalla nisivoccia sul culo rico
gabriele uomo gq davanti a termostato
gabriele attore a cannes con termostato
è 110 foto di gruppo di coloro non sono
morti sono io
solo lui come veniva
[Musica]
16 grazie di tutto ti faccio vedere gli
inviti addio al giorno di gas dovuto
portare per le fasce satura falegnameria
quasi tutti che sostiene viva ma salva
la cas che ne abbiamo quanti ne per chi
ne serve per me comune e che prevenire è
meglio che curare questa è bella e un
bel marroni e questa è la iv stagione va
bene estate primavera guardi siamo a cui
misure diamo noi fate dottori fanno
tutto nude che mi preoccupai però son
quanti cosa che forma tanto il lasciamo
shock e sharm el sheick guardi ecco
questa è pronta se vuole ma italiani a
queste universale a chiave do bene che
sta un po stretta sui fianchi questa
sfida queste sono slim da quelli di
fiammiferi uscivano dakar
io di solito dormo così è usa ma dopo un
saluto della pace l'aria così detta pure
così dell'atto come mi metterebbe così
come sta messa adesso con le mani così
per le cose basta barriera così bella è
bella si direbbe tutto il sonorizzata
l'aise fa rumore dà fastidio a nessuno
studente donne chiede chi dispone sempre
potevano star funerale due è per forza
se no cosa che pensano prima che
ammazzano e poi che piangono
[Risate]
123 trattenga fiato è ok come va vabbè
poi ci mettiamo una piccola bazzurro è
che i fiori sente niente
ecco io avevo detto che era tutto a
posto che faccio lascio guardi e facendo
pure un altro articolo se vuole il
cuscino se po fa leggermente più io
dormo e bassa pardi ce n'è un'altra che
il top di gamma ma ecco stessa ferrari
degas compresi bellocchi questi ci
faccio metto certo costa m però possiamo
mandare finanziamento come si può morto
che siano oltre l'infinito nera chi vuoi
se poi qualsiasi colore
melissa hill bud nera si può avere mar
cristo compreso cristo completo e siamo
tutti i cristi diciamo pure madonne
certe madonne che c'è attenzione perché
ciò coricare dell'asse noto ma portava
da solo
sapere necessità di rivolta non so se la
crisi come questo ovviamente
ma se volete guardi dentro lo fa da
montare se timori dei volta dietro
abitudini che faccio fuori limite può
dire che gli heat ritiene questo ci si
può affogare tutti i diritti del corpo
s'oppone tutto boni che sento qualcosa
si sente niente sarà modo come una tomba
era buio e luce e luce sia mazza
vogliamo provare altro dei vivai già
convinto con lui ci sia questo il lavoro
nostro se vuole mettiamo curanti so come
ringraziarla e perfetto senza martino
parla con lei o quell'altro di se
sommiamo tutti uguali io li faccio
sapere se sentimo sì magari privatistica
piazze sentivo un po prima magari felice
questa così è questa questa mancata
cremato c'entra
l'ingrediente segreto e l'amore per
essere accettati per essere ricordati
per essere amati siamo disposti anche a
morire come dei guerrieri
ma è molto più importante vivere come s
e non intendo solo quelli che combattono
sul campo di battaglia i numeri ieri
sono coloro che esaltano le virtù sono
coloro che hanno il coraggio di vivere
intensamente la propria vita portando
avanti le proprie idee e non dei più
grandi guerrieri della storia e gandhi
ha vinto una guerra con la sua politica
della non violenza
i ragazzi sacchetti da guarda grandi
bello dice verso per caso ragazzi borsa
sotto poi anche gli under ai suoi lati
oscuri ragazzi
[Musica]
che cosa c'entrano i guerrieri con
questo video
niente niente non possiamo prevedere la
nostra morte a prenderne consapevolezza
si farà vivere più intensamente il
nostro oggi quante persone morte
ricordiamo tutti i giorni e quanti vivi
non cerchiamo più se sapessimo che fosse
sempre il nostro ultimo giorno forse
saremo liberi da schemi da gelosie che
da invidie e chissà che forse anche noi
potremmo vivere come i bambini a santa
fè e con occhi da cerbiatto bambi
da darmi con occhi da cerbiatto bambi
con una come di fondamenta ai
grattacieli il mondo da oggi ha perso
una cometa a bandi ma gabriele bambini
capire le bande non è mai caduto bambi
cir comando iscrivetevi attivate la
campanella bambi e a 50.000 like lo
faremo risorgere grazie bambini
[Musica]